we are wrapping up our wonder woman week
with gal going full glam
and dropping this red carpet confession
what is a secret hidden talent that you
have that folks at home
might be surprised to learn we can all
work really really
well on zero amount of of sleep
yeah is that a talent gal in the cast
spent seven months shooting in locations
like england
spain and the canary islands all with
the blessing of the original wonder
woman
linda carter who made a surprise
appearance at the virtual premiere
this little glam thing is my homage
miguel i wouldn't poke
this film inspired love
acceptance as cheesy as it might sound
but the only solution
to bring us all together is just love
love saves the day
her greatest weapon is compassion hope
and kindness
trying to break up this love fest pedro
pascal he plays mastermind max lord
he's an evil genius who left the
fighting to gal and kristen wiggs
cheetah so nice for the women to take
that
over by they're the ones that are
kicking butt
[Music]
well aren't you resourceful it was
incredible
it really really was especially if it
means that i will not be taking the salt
bath
or you know asking for ice packs at the
end of the day
pedro joins the dc universe just as
pre-production on season three of the
mandalorian is set to begin
so how do star wars fans compare i
remember stepping out onto that stage
and it was like being on the receiving
end of a jet oh my god
it was just a wash with like cheer and
you know and i thought you know
i could get used to this careful
have you gotten used to it there hasn't
been enough of it to get used to yet
i look forward to getting this to it